there is another couple of hundred for
when that's done the city of London woke
up to a currency crisis
the pound sent tumbling on Asian markets
to its lowest ever level against the
dollar a global vote of no confidence in
government plans to fuel growth with
borrowing if the growth doesn't come
through as expected or doesn't come
through quickly enough the the size of
that debt is going to be bigger than it
was and the cost of service it is going
to be bigger than it was and and you're
into a little bit of a doom Loop there
are shades of the 1970s here in terms of
when when the government had to go cap
and hand to the IMF so that's that's
really what's in the back of of Traders
Minds at the moment I'm not going to
make any comment now 72 hours after his
statement triggered the sell-off
quasi-quarting had nothing to say
publicly but the treasury has promised
he will provide more detail of how debt
will be brought down in November in a
coordinated intervention with the bank
of England governor who said in a
statement the bank is monitoring
developments in financial markets very
closely in light of the significant
replay writing of financial assets the
monetary policy committee will not
hesitate to change interest rates by as
much as needed to return inflation to
the two percent Target sustainably in
the medium term in line with its remit
when that meeting comes in November
markets are forecasting Andrew Bailey
will have to announce a rate rise as
high as two percent to keep inflation in
check he will be concerned at the the
moves in the markets over the last
couple of days and particularly if they
continue
because every fall in the pound brings
greater inflation looking forward and a
greater squeeze on household finances
after tumultuous day that saw the cost
of government borrowing rise even as the
pound fell the bank's statement is an
attempt to reassure markets but
emergency interventions like this are
extremely rare and only come in times of
Crisis International investors though
are so rattled by new government policy
it might not be the last
a week currency drives up the cost of
imports including food and fuel for
consumers already feeling the pinch I
only work part-time well I am thinking
do I need to work hours at work
um to keep up with the lifestyle that we
have as well to maintain and we're only
in here for a couple of little bits
today
so it's getting ridiculous all the
financial services and industries and
followers that I read they all say
they're scared and they're worried and
it's when professionals are saying that
they're scared that makes me worried
then the turmoil has forced the Halifax
Skipton Building Society and virgin
money to withdraw mortgage products as
customers rush to secure fixed rates
amplifying the market message that with
bank and government policy pulling in
different directions something will have
to give Paul Kelso's Sky News in the
city of London